In October 2003, a guy was brought into the psychiatric emergency room at Bellevue Hospital in New York City. Dr. Joel Gold was the chief attending psychiatrist that day and saw him.
2003年10月，一名男子被送进了纽约市贝尔维尤医院的精神科急诊室。那天是乔尔·戈德医生值班，他负责接诊。
He felt that his life was essentially a reality show, that he's been recorded for years, that everyone in his life was an actor reading from a script. And he came to New York essentially to test this hypothesis.
他觉得自己的生活本质上是一场真人秀，他已经被录制了好几年，生命中出现的每个人都是拿着剧本的演员。他来纽约基本上是为了验证这个假设。
He thought that maybe 9/11 was faked, just to get a reaction out of him on reality TV.
他认为“9·11”事件可能是伪造的，只是为了让他在真人秀节目中做出反应。
And if he came to New York, and if the World Trade Centers were still standing, he would know that that was in fact the case. If in fact they had been destroyed, then he would admit that perhaps he was delusional.
如果他来到纽约，如果世贸中心大楼还在，他就知道这确实是事实。如果它们真的被摧毁了，那他会承认自己可能产生了妄想。
But once he got to New York, instead of visiting the Twin Towers, he walked into the United Nations and asked for asylum-- asylum from a TV show that was filming him without his consent, 24 hours a day, which, you know, is how he ended up in Bellevue.
但当他到达纽约后，他没有去参观双子塔，而是走进联合国寻求庇护——寻求保护，免受一个未经他同意、每天24小时拍摄他的电视节目的困扰，这就是他最终被送到贝尔维尤医院的原因。
Dr. Gold didn't think much of this. People show up at Bellevue with lots of weird delusions all the time. And then a few months later, another guy walks in with the same idea, that he was being filmed 24/7 and broadcast around the world. And the second guy, like the first one, mentioned a film, the 1998 movie The Truman Show .
戈德医生对此并不感到惊讶。总有人带着各种奇怪的妄想来到贝尔维尤。几个月后，另一个人带着同样的念头走了进来，认为自己正被全天候拍摄并向全世界转播。和第一个人一样，第二个人也提到了1998年的电影《楚门的世界》。
Both of them name The Truman Show by name. They said, my life is like The Truman Show .
他们俩都指名道姓地提到了《楚门的世界》。他们说，我的生活就像《楚门的世界》。
Truman is played by Jim Carrey. He's filmed all day, every day, on a program that is broadcast to billions of people around the globe. His wife, his best friend, everybody around him is an actor. Everybody knows this is a TV show but him, until one day, he starts to see clues that make him suspicious.
楚门由金·凯瑞扮演。他每天每时每刻都被拍摄，节目向全球数十亿人转播。他的妻子、他最好的朋友，他身边的每个人都是演员。除了他自己，所有人都知道这是一场电视秀，直到有一天，他开始发现一些让他产生怀疑的线索。
And just to be clear, you're not saying that the Truman Show necessarily triggered this, like, people watched The Truman Show and suddenly something in their brain snaps.
为了明确一下，你并不是说《楚门的世界》必然触发了这些症状，比如人们看了这部电影，大脑里的某根弦就突然断了。
Yeah, exactly. On the contrary, I think. It's just when people are becoming psychotic, perhaps if you've seen the movie and that's kicking around in your head, you might say, yes, this is what's happening to me.
是的，完全正确。相反，我认为，当人们开始出现精神病症状时，如果恰好看过这部电影，且脑子里有这个概念，他们可能会说，是的，这就是发生在我身上的事情。
If your psychosis includes both paranoia and a sense that you are very, very important-- what psychiatrists called grandiosity-- 30 years ago, you know, you might think that the CIA or the KGB is watching you all the time. These days, you have another possible explanation-- reality TV. A few months later, a third patient showed up with the same delusion, and a few months after that, a fourth. Dr. Gold started calling it The Truman Show delusion. He's written a book about it with his brother Ian called Suspicious Minds . In one case in the book, a patient, a super smart guy, an academic, very altruistic, believed that he was part of an elaborate game show and the world was watching him and betting on everything that he did.
如果你的精神病表现包括偏执，以及认为自己非常、非常重要——精神科医生称之为“夸大妄想”——那么30年前，你可能会认为中央情报局或克格勃一直在监视你。现在，你有了解释的另一种可能——真人秀。几个月后，第三位有同样妄想的病人出现了，又过了几个月，第四位也来了。戈德医生开始将其称为“楚门的世界妄想”。他与兄弟伊恩合写了一本名为《多疑的心》的书。书中有一个案例，一位病人——一个超级聪明、学术背景、非常有无私精神的人——坚信自己是一档精心策划的游戏节目的参赛者，全世界都在看着他，并为他所做的一切下注。
And this was a really fun thing that everyone would be doing online. And the monies collected would go to charities all over the world. And then every single human being on earth would be given some amount of money, and the world would be bettered for it.
他认为这是一件大家都会在网上参与的有趣事情。筹集到的资金将捐赠给世界各地的慈善机构。然后，地球上的每个人都会得到一笔钱，世界会因此变得更美好。
One of the things that he included in his delusion, you write in your book, is that he has the thought that he actually was the mastermind who created this game show that he was on, and that he controlled it and he knew the rules when he had originally created the show. But somehow he had forgotten that, and all the rules-- which is so interesting, because, of course, it's true. Like he did invent the game show. And the only fact that he's missing is that it's not real. It's all in his own head.
你在书中写到，他妄想的内容之一是他认为自己实际上是这档游戏节目的策划者，是他控制着节目，并在最初创建时就制定了规则。但不知何故他忘记了这一切，也忘了所有的规则——这太有趣了，因为这当然是真的。就像他确实发明了这个游戏节目一样。他唯一缺失的事实是，这根本不是真的，一切都在他自己的脑子里。
That's, yeah, an interesting way of putting it. It is kind of fantastical.
这是一个非常有趣的说法。这确实有些奇幻。
And heartbreaking.
而且令人心碎。
It is.
确实。
Like part of him knows he made it up.
就像他内心深处知道这一切是他编造的。
Absolutely.
绝对是这样。
But he can't grasp the whole reality.
但他无法完全把握现实。
He does not remember. At one point, he suggests that he told his best friends, "This is what I'm going to do. You're going to run the show. But you will now hypnotize me, and I will forget what we're talking about now so we can do this really good deed for humanity."
他不记得了。有一次他甚至提出，他告诉他最好的朋友：“这就是我要做的。你们要负责运营节目。但你们现在要对我进行催眠，我会忘记我们刚才谈论的内容，这样我们就能为人类做这件善事了。”
Some of these patients respond to treatment, some don't-- same as with other delusions and psychoses. But Dr. Gold says that if they do come back to reality--
有些病人对治疗有反应，有些则没有——就像其他妄想症和精神病患者一样。但戈德医生说，如果他们确实回到了现实——
Some feel great relief if they've been persecuted. It's quite embarrassing, if you think about it. Every moment of your life, I mean, when you're in the shower, literally everything is filmed, so they feel quite good about it. At the same time, there's a certain sadness that they're not particularly important.
有些人会感到巨大的解脱，如果他们之前一直感到受迫害的话。如果你想想看，这其实相当尴尬。你的每一刻生活，比如你在洗澡时，一切都被拍了下来，所以他们对此感觉还不错。与此同时，也会有一种失落感，因为他们并没有那么重要。
Do they miss being the most famous person in the world?
他们会怀念成为世界上最出名的人的感觉吗？
No question, there are some who feel that that's a huge loss. At the same time, I think they return to the notion that they're mentally ill, which in and of itself is an unfortunate and sad thing.
毫无疑问，有些人觉得那是一种巨大的损失。但同时，我认为他们会回到自己患有精神疾病的认知中，这本身就是一件不幸且悲伤的事情。
Psychosis aside, I think all this illustrates so clearly there's a downside and an upside to being on stage for the whole world to see, a human spectacle against your will. And today on our program, we have people who became just that. They have an experience so few of us have, that we all get to see from afar. They are on display for everybody, and not because they chose it. What that feels like, the positive parts and the negative side and the real life reality, the whole thing, from the WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
抛开精神病不谈，我认为这一切清晰地说明，站在世界舞台上被全程观看——一种违背你意愿的人类奇观——既有坏处也有好处。今天在我们的节目中，我们就邀请了成为了这种“景观”的人。他们拥有极少数人能有的体验，而我们所有人都能从远处观望。他们被展示给所有人看，却不是因为他们自己的选择。那是什么感觉，积极的一面、消极的一面，以及真实的现实，这一切，来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "I Am the Eggplant," koo koo kachoob. In the TV genre that's devoted to pure human spectacle, reality TV, you know, people fight drunkenly in hot tubs. They eat live spiders for money. But none of that can hold a candle to this show, a show that aired in Japan all the way back in 1998. It was called Susunu! Denpa Shonen . And one of its segments in particular got the attention of our producers, Stephanie Foo.
第一幕，“我是茄子”，库库卡乔（注：披头士歌词梗）。在致力于纯粹人类奇观的电视类型中，也就是真人秀，你知道，人们会在按摩浴缸里醉酒打架，为了钱活吞蜘蛛。但这些节目与接下来我们要说的这部节目相比都逊色不少，那是一部1998年在日本播出的节目。它的名字叫《前进！电波少年》。其中一个片段引起了我们制片人斯蒂芬妮·富的注意。
The segment is called "Sweepstakes Life." It starts the way a lot of these shows do, with a bunch of people at an audition. One guy beats out everyone else. He's 22 years old, a comedian just starting out in his career. His name is Nasubi.
这个片段叫“抽奖生活”。它和很多真人秀的开头一样，一群人在参加试镜。一个人胜出了。他22岁，是一个刚起步的喜剧演员。他的名字叫茄子。
Nasubi.
茄子。
Nasubi means "eggplant" in Japanese, a nickname he got because he has a long face. The producers tell him they have a unique idea for a show, something they've never tried before. It may or may not air. But if it does, he'll be the star. He'll be famous.
茄子在日语里是“茄子”的意思，因为他脸很长，所以得了这个绰号。制片人告诉他，他们有一个独特的节目创意，以前从没尝试过。节目可能会播，也可能不会。但如果播了，他就是主角。他会出名。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
The producers blindfold him, put him in a car, and take  him to a small apartment. Then they tell him to take his clothes off.
制片人蒙住他的眼睛，把他塞进车里，带到一个小公寓。然后告诉他把衣服脱了。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
That wipes the grin off his face.
这让他脸上的笑容瞬间消失了。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
It wasn't just my personal sort of shame or issues about nudity, per say. My dad is a cop. And when I first announced that my career choice was going to be comedy, he was not thrilled. And we had to go through some things to get him around to the idea. He said the one thing that I must never do in public is strip.
这不仅仅是我个人的羞耻感或对裸露的顾虑。我父亲是个警察。当我第一次宣布我的职业选择是喜剧时，他并不高兴。我们经历了很多波折才让他接受了这个想法。他说我唯一绝对不能在公共场合做的事就是脱衣服。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
So there I was. And then this guilt towards-- I was breaking the promise to my father as publicly as possible.
所以我当时就处在那种境地。那种对父亲违背承诺的愧疚感，还是以最公开的方式。
But he strips. He grabs a pillow, holds it over his groin, and looks around the room. There's no chair in the room, no bed, just a coffee table and magazines, tons of magazines. The producers tell him that from now on, if he wants food, clothes, he will have to win them by entering sweepstakes in those magazines. They give him postcards to send in for prize drawings. He'll be freed from the apartment after he wins 1 million yen, or $10,000 worth of prizes.
但他还是脱了。他抓起一个枕头遮住胯部，环顾房间。房间里没有椅子，没有床，只有一张咖啡桌和杂志，堆积如山的杂志。制片人告诉他，从现在起，如果他想要食物或衣服，就必须通过参加那些杂志上的抽奖来赢得。他们给他明信片让他寄出去参加抽奖。直到他赢得100万日元，也就是价值1万美元的奖品，他才能离开这个公寓。
Until then, he isn't allowed any outside contact with the world. He can't call his family. He can't talk to friends. And oh, they tell him, "Don't forget to put tapes in this little camera here every two hours and record yourself. We'll come pick up the tapes once a day." And then they say, "All right, later." Nasubi screams, "Are you for real?"
在此之前，他不被允许与外界有任何联系。他不能给家人打电话，不能和朋友说话。噢，他们告诉他：“别忘了每两小时往这台小摄像机里放一盘磁带，录下你的一举一动。我们会每天来取磁带。”然后他们说：“好了，回见。”茄子大叫：“你们是认真的吗？”
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Nasubi says he'd signed no contract. But he didn't have anything better to do, so he sat down and wrote, and soon was entering 200 to 300 contests a day. And while he waited for prizes to arrive, he had no food. Nasubi got frighteningly thin very quickly. You could see the sharp angles of his collarbones.
茄子说他没签合同。但他也没别的事可做，于是他坐下来开始写，很快每天要参加200到300场比赛。在等待奖品到来的过程中，他没有食物。茄子很快就瘦得吓人。你能清楚看到他锁骨的线条。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Well, starvation is a good word for it. The staff got together and would give me basically a very simple little bread each day. So I had bread and water, essentially, for the first two weeks. But then as soon as the results started to come in, then that stopped and everything shifted over entirely to the things that I could win through sweepstakes.
嗯，饥饿是最好的词来形容。工作人员聚在一起，基本上每天只给我一小块非常简单的面包。所以前两周我基本上只吃面包喝水。但只要结果开始出来，这种情况就停止了，一切完全转向我通过抽奖赢得的东西。
After two weeks, he finally won some sugary drinks. A few days after that, he won a bag of rice. When the postman dropped it off, it was like Christmas. Nasubi danced like a madman.
两周后，他终于赢到了一些含糖饮料。几天后，他赢得了一袋米。当邮递员送货上门时，那简直就像过圣诞节一样。茄子疯狂地跳起舞来。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Were you trying to be a good performer and be funny when you were doing that? Or was it just really genuine joy?
你在做那些动作时，是想做一个好的表演者、表现得有趣吗？还是那是纯粹真诚的快乐？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Well, initially, of course, I was there as a performer, and I wanted to be a comedian. But somewhere in the middle, the whole business of staying alive became my full-time occupation. So I think what you saw, if you saw me dancing, it was really just a human being expressing great joy.
嗯，最初，我当然是以表演者的身份去的，我想成为一名喜剧演员。但在中间的某个阶段，维持生命变成了我的全职工作。所以我想你看到的，如果看到我在跳舞，那真的只是一个人类在表达巨大的喜悦。
So he danced for this package of rice. But then he stopped short. He realized he didn't own a pot to cook the rice in. But after a couple days of failed attempts, he figured out that if he put some rice in an empty drink container and left it near his single gas burner, it eventually turned into a kind of porridge.
所以他为了这一包米跳舞。但随后他停了下来。他意识到他没有煮饭的锅。但在尝试几天失败后，他想出如果把米放在一个空饮料罐里，放在他唯一的燃气炉旁边，最终就能变成一种粥。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
And I could eat delicious rice every day. I remember how good that felt. And then there was the slow trepidation as it started to vanish. And then it ran out. And the only food substitute that I had been able to win in a sweepstakes was dog food. You know, after, let's say, six weeks of eating dog food, when then I was able to get more rice and it arrived, I really felt a special kind of joy at being able to return to humanity in a sense and taste delicious rice again every day.
我每天都能吃到美味的米饭了。我记得那种感觉有多好。然后，当米开始快消失时，那种慢慢到来的不安感又出现了。最后米吃完了。我在抽奖中能赢得的唯一食物替代品就是狗粮。你知道，比如在吃了六周狗粮后，当我又能获得米饭并送达时，那种重新回到人类社会，又能每天吃到美味米饭的感觉，我真的感受到一种特别的快乐。
Back then, there was a kind of sweepstakes mania in Japan. The country was in the middle of a terrible recession. And some wondered whether one could subsist entirely on their winnings. And so when Sweepstakes Life debuted, almost immediately after Nasubi was first shut in the room, it was an instant hit. Nasubi had no idea. He didn't even know he was on TV. He believed what the producers had told him, that he'd record some videotapes, and maybe someday it would end up on the air.
当时，日本有一种“抽奖热”。国家正处于严重的经济衰退之中。有些人怀疑一个人是否能完全依靠奖品生存。所以当《抽奖生活》开播时，几乎在茄子被关进房间后，它就成了瞬间的热门节目。茄子完全不知道。他甚至不知道自己在电视上。他相信了制片人的话，以为自己只是录制一些录像带，也许有一天会被播出。
On television, Nasubi's groin was hidden by a purple cartoon eggplant that floated around as he moved. Everything he did was accentuated with ridiculous "boing boing" sound effects, and puffy rainbow letters floated above his head.
在电视上，茄子的胯部被一个紫色的卡通茄子挡住，随着他的动作来回晃动。他所做的一切都配上了滑稽的“Boing Boing”音效，五颜六色的浮夸字母在他头顶飘过。
[BOINGING]
[弹簧音效]
[GAME SHOW NOISES]
[游戏节目音效]
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
But these effects popped up just as often when Nasubi was despondent. The show took every chance to poke fun at him, whether he was muttering to himself, dancing around, or doing terrible headstands-- you know, the dumb stuff you do when you think no one's watching, except people were.
但即便茄子意志消沉时，这些效果也会弹出。节目抓住每一个机会取笑他，无论他是在自言自语、乱跳，还是在做糟糕的倒立——你知道，当你以为没人看着时你会做的傻事，除了当时人们都在看着。
For context, in the US, Game of Thrones usually has around 9 million viewers. Nasubi had 16 million in a country less than half the size of ours. People thought Nasubi was the funniest comedy act they'd ever seen. And I have to admit, as a viewer, once in a while, when Nasubi got something really awesome in the mail, I couldn't help it. I laughed, too, even though I knew how much he was suffering. I couldn't help it. His unfiltered joy is contagious. Though as a foreigner watching Sweepstakes Life , most of the time, when the studio audience cracked up, I felt sick. I thought, what could possibly be funny about this?
作为一个背景参考，在美国，《权力的游戏》通常有大约900万观众。而在一个面积不到我们一半的国家，茄子拥有1600万观众。人们认为茄子是他们看过的最搞笑的喜剧表演。我必须承认，作为观众，偶尔当茄子真的收到了一些很棒的东西时，我忍不住了。我也笑了，尽管我知道他遭受了多少折磨。我忍不住。他那种未经过滤的快乐具有感染力。虽然作为一个外国人看着《抽奖生活》，大多数时候，当演播室观众大笑时，我感到恶心。我想，这有什么可笑的？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I mean, that was maybe a time when Japan was going through some things and they needed to sort of do that. Roughly 50 years of prosperity has finally come to a close, and people really uncertain about their futures. You know, I think people just tended to watch the show and say, you know, I got it bad. But look at poor Nasubi. He's got it worse.
我的意思是，那也许是日本经历了一些事情、人们需要这样做的时候。大约50年的繁荣终于画上了句号，人们对未来真的感到不安。你知道，我认为人们只是倾向于看这个节目然后说，我的情况很糟，但看看可怜的茄子，他更惨。
Now there's a lot more awareness of the weak and of people who need extra support. I don't think I think the average Japanese today would think it was funny that there was a guy naked in a room somewhere.
现在，人们对弱势群体和需要额外支持的人有了更多的关注。我不认为今天的普通日本观众会觉得一个人赤身裸体被关在房间里是一件可笑的事。
Nasubi won hundreds of prizes. But many of them were useless to him-- Spice Girls tickets, for example, or a TV with no cable, or a bicycle. He sent away for clothes, but never won anything he could wear. He was naked the entire time he was in that room, for the entire show. And as the weeks went by, then months, Nasubi started to look less and less sane. He grew a beard. His hair was wild. And he started talking differently, slower.
茄子赢得了数百个奖品。但其中很多对他来说毫无用处——比如辣妹合唱团的门票，或者是没有线缆的电视机，或者一辆自行车。他寄出申请想要衣服，但从来没赢过任何他能穿的东西。他在房间里的整个过程中、整个节目期间都是裸体的。随着几周、几个月过去，茄子看起来越来越不正常。他留起了胡子，头发蓬乱。他开始以不同的方式说话，语速变得缓慢。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
He'd make really creepy faces into the camera. At one point, he won some toys and he started talking to them. He took a stuffed seal for a walk around the apartment. An action figure became his sensei, and he got life advice from it.
他会对着镜头做非常怪异的表情。有一次，他赢得了一些玩具，开始和它们说话。他带着一只毛绒海豹在公寓里散步。一个动作人偶成了他的老师，他甚至从它那里获取人生建议。
And if, right now, you're sitting there thinking, how in God's good name is this possible? Why was this allowed? Imprisonment, solitary confinement, starvation. Watching, I thought, this isn't a reality TV show. It's a psychological experiment made public. Plus boing boings, of course.
如果此时你正坐在那里想，这怎么可能呢？为什么会被允许？监禁、单独禁闭、饥饿。看着节目，我心想，这不是真人秀。这是一个被公开的心理实验。当然，还配上了那些滑稽音效。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
[BOINGING]
[弹簧音效]
Was there anything preventing you from backing out at that point? Like, was the door locked?
当时有什么能阻止你退出的吗？门锁了吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
No, there was no lock on the door. And producers later asked me, so why didn't you escape? I was naked, so I would have had to go outside naked and seek help. But I don't think that that's what kept me in there. The only thing I really have to say is that I said I'd do it, and I do what I say.
没有，门上没锁。制片人后来问我，那你为什么不逃跑？因为我当时是裸体的，如果逃跑就必须赤身裸体地跑到外面求助。但我不认为这就是留住我的原因。我唯一要说的是，我说过我会做，我就必须说到做到。
That was it? The only reason? I kept asking him, but wait, really, why?
就因为这个？唯一的理由？我一直问他，但等等，真的是这样吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
There's a phrase, [JAPANESE], "the Japanese spirit," which is just that you sort of stick through. You endure things. When you're given something, whether it's easy or whether it's hard, you just really do. You're obliged to follow it through.
有一个词叫“大和魂”，即“日本精神”，意思就是你要坚持到底。你要忍受一切。当你被赋予一件事，无论简单还是困难，你真的就要做下去。你有义务完成它。
Nasubi did finally win $10,000 worth of prizes. It took him almost an entire year. But at last, he'd completed the challenge. When he reached his goal, producers didn't tell him anything about it. Instead, they snuck into his apartment in the middle of the night, put a blindfold on him, took him out to a car, gave him clothes. Nasubi seemed to think this was a good thing. He was laughing, giggling.
茄子最终确实赢得了价值1万美元的奖品。这几乎花了他整整一年。但最后，他完成了挑战。当他达到目标时，制片人什么都没告诉他。相反，他们在深夜潜入他的公寓，蒙上他的眼睛，把他带到车里，给了他衣服。茄子似乎觉得这是件好事。他在笑，在咯咯笑。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
[STUDIO AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众大笑]
But when he took the blindfold off, he found out he'd been taken to Korea.
但当他摘下眼罩时，发现自己被带到了韩国。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
When I got off on the other side in Korea, I took off the mask. And they said, "Congratulations. You've achieved your $10,000. This is your reward. You get to have a trip in Korea." So I got to do a little sightseeing that day. And I thought, oh, wow, that was a long thing, boy, what I've been through.
当我下车到达韩国那边时，我摘下了眼罩。他们说：“恭喜你。你达到了1万美元的目标。这是你的奖励。你可以去韩国旅游。”那天我确实去观光了一点。我心想，哇，这真是漫长的一段经历啊，伙计，我经历了些什么。
But then at the end of the day, they took me back to my room and there was the exact same room set up in the exact same way.
但到了那天结束时，他们把我带回了房间，发现房间的布置和原来一模一样。
They'd recreated his little apartment, complete with the magazines, the stuffed seal, the postcards, exactly how he'd left it, except in Korea. And they told him, great. Now all you have to do is start over and win your airfare back home.
他们重新搭建了他的小公寓，连杂志、毛绒海豹、明信片都和原来的一模一样，只是地点在韩国。他们告诉他，太棒了。现在你要做的就是从头开始，赢回回家的机票。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
This was just like somebody just had pulled the floor out from under me, and I just fell. I didn't know that humans could be that cruel.
这感觉就像有人抽掉了我脚下的地板，我就那样掉下去了。我不知道人类竟然可以如此残忍。
Did you feel like you were going insane?
你当时感觉自己快疯了吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
If anything, the opposite of insane. I lost all energy. It's like somebody had just, like, sucked the life out of me. I didn't want to talk. I didn't want to breathe. I didn't want to move a muscle. I had reached the end. I was finished.
如果说有什么，那恰恰相反，不像疯了，我失去了所有能量。就像有人刚刚把我的生命抽干了一样。我不想说话。不想呼吸。不想动弹。我已经到了尽头。我完了。
I told the producer that I wouldn't do it. I refused. And we went back and forth for quite a while, actually. But in the end, kudos to his skill as a negotiator. I did give in and do the last section of it.
我告诉制片人我不会再做了。我拒绝了。实际上我们僵持了很久。但最后，不得不佩服他谈判技巧的高超，我妥协了，完成了最后一部分。
Why did you do it? What did he say that actually convinced you to do it?
你为什么这么做？他说了什么最终让你同意了？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Well, it was just that I got exhausted, if anything. I mean, he wasn't leaving. I couldn't just sort of get up and storm out. I had made no preparations for being in Korea. And so at the end, I just said, yeah, whatever. And so I continued.
嗯，是因为我精疲力竭了。我的意思是，他根本没打算走。我没法站起来冲出去。我在韩国没做任何准备。所以最后，我就说，好吧，随便吧。于是我继续了。
After all, he was naked with no money in another country. If you watch the clip, the producers just tell him he's trapped, show him looking shocked, and cut away. The studio audience laughs.
毕竟，他当时赤身裸体，在异国他乡身无分文。如果你看那段视频，制片人只是告诉他被困住了，镜头拍到他震惊的样子，然后就切断了。演播室观众哄堂大笑。
[STUDIO AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众大笑]
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Nasubi continued his writing routine for four more months. And then the final episode aired. Picture it. The producers sneak into Nasubi's room and blindfold him again, dress him, drive him to another location. They release him in yet another bare room. And he sighs and instinctively takes off all his clothes. Then, suddenly, all four of the walls around him fall down.
茄子又继续了四个月的写作日常。然后最后一集播出了。想象一下。制片人潜入茄子的房间，再次蒙上他的眼睛，给他穿上衣服，开车带他到另一个地点。他们把他在另一个空荡荡的房间里放下。他叹了口气，本能地脱掉所有衣服。然后，突然，他周围的四面墙全部倒塌了。
[CLATTERING]
[倒塌声]
[SHRIEKING]
[尖叫声]
That's him screaming. Turns out he's on stage in a huge studio in Japan in front of an enormous audience.
那是他的尖叫。原来他正站在日本一个巨大的演播室舞台上，面前是庞大的观众群。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
"Nasubi, congratulations on your goal."
“茄子，恭喜你达成目标。”
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Nasubi looks horrified. Two television hosts cautiously approach him and talk to him like a baby, telling him congratulations.
茄子看起来非常惊恐。两名电视主持人谨慎地走近他，像哄小孩一样跟他说话，向他表示祝贺。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Nasubi says, frightened, "My house fell down. And there's all these people here."
茄子害怕地说：“我的房子塌了。而且这里有这么多人。”
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[笑声和掌声]
"It's finally over," presses the host. "You're finished." Nasubi should be happy. But he looks thoroughly weirded out. Remember, Nasubi didn't even know he was being broadcast. The producers told him that it was an experiment, that they didn't know if he'd ever make it on air. So he's blown away when they tell him about the TV show, that a secret camera in his apartment once even broadcast a 24-hour live stream of his actions.
“终于结束了，”主持人催促道，“你完成了。”茄子应该高兴才对，但他看起来完全被吓坏了。记住，茄子甚至不知道自己被转播了。制片人告诉他这是一个实验，他们甚至不知道节目是否会播出。所以当他们告诉他这一切是一档电视节目，甚至公寓里的秘密摄像头曾进行过24小时现场直播时，他被彻底震撼了。
They tell him his diaries were published and are bestsellers. Clips from him enjoying a specific brand of ramen turned into commercials and endorsement deals. He was on the cover of magazines. Then they play a bunch of clips from the show. Nasubi blinks. He says, "Did I do that? That was me?"
他们告诉他，他的日记被出版并成了畅销书。他享受某种特定口味拉面的片段变成了广告和代言合同。他登上了杂志封面。然后他们播放了节目的一堆片段。茄子眨着眼睛，他说：“那是我做的？那是我吗？”
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
And so I sat there, realizing that this new life was-- I was no longer just a nobody. The entire nation had been watching me for 15 months. And you know to be honest, I thought, well, what the hell? What is my country coming to? I was very happy that my journey was not for nothing. But it's still weird.
所以我坐在那里，意识到这种新生活是——我不再只是一个无名小卒。整个国家已经盯着我看了15个月。老实说，我当时想，到底是怎么回事？我的国家变成什么样了？我很高兴我的旅程不是徒劳的。但这还是很诡异。
Unsurprisingly, Nasubi left the show with some scars. He had a lot of trouble holding a conversation for six months. And he felt sweaty and uncomfortable in clothes for a year. And his role didn't help his comedy career like he'd hoped. He was mostly offered roles that required him to be goofy and naked. He's a D-list celebrity now and has the dwindling bank account to match.
不出所料，茄子带着一些创伤离开了节目。他花了六个月的时间才学会如何正常对话。他甚至穿了一年的衣服后才觉得不那么汗流浃背和不适。这个角色并没有像他希望的那样帮助他的喜剧事业。他得到的角色大多是要求他扮傻和裸露的。他现在是一个三流艺人，银行账户里的钱也越来越少。
And talking to him, it felt like he's really worked hard to turn that traumatic experience into a positive story he tells himself. He even says he's thankful for the experience.
与他交谈时，感觉他真的努力想把那段创伤经历变成一个他讲给自己听的积极故事。他甚至说他很感激这段经历。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
It was-- I don't want to overstate it, but it was kind of meditative in a way. I had a lot of time to think about my life and a lot of time to think about a lot of stuff.
这确实是——我不想夸大它，但这在某种程度上是一种冥想。我有大量的时间来思考我的人生，思考很多事情。
That certainly is a very zen way to look at it.
那确实是一种非常禅意的看待方式。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Well, I mean, it's 10-some years since I finished, since I did that project. And after that, everything has been much easier and much better, obviously. I'm able to deal with things. I see things happening, or I see situations around myself, and I think that's nothing like what I went through in that room.
嗯，我的意思是，距离我完成那个项目已经十多年了。在那之后，一切都变得容易多了，好得多了。我能处理事情。看到周围发生的情况，我会想，这跟我在那房间里经历的相比根本不算什么。
And people still remember him. That's more than one could say for most of the Denpa Shonen characters. None of them lasted as long as Nasubi or became as famous. The show ended in 2002, after its ratings began to drop.
人们仍然记得他。这比大多数《电波少年》里的角色要好。他们中没人像茄子那样坚持那么久，或者变得那么出名。该节目在2002年收视率下降后结束。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I came out of the whole thing, in a sense, with the very best of possible results. A lot of people were not so fortunate. There were terrible things that happened related to the show.
我从整个事情中走出来，从某种意义上说，得到了尽可能最好的结果。很多人就没那么幸运了。与该节目相关发生了很多可怕的事情。
One contestant on Denpa Shonen almost died of dehydration while trying to hitchhike across Africa. Some people were starved until they completed various challenges. Another man was forced to go into a gay club in Australia and offer condoms to men until he was assaulted. The video cuts out, but you can hear him scream.
《电波少年》的一名参赛者在试图徒步穿越非洲时差点脱水而死。有些人被饿到完成各种挑战。另一个人被强迫进入澳大利亚的一家同性恋俱乐部，向男人们推销避孕套，直到他遭到袭击。视频中断了，但你可以听到他的尖叫。
And the mastermind behind all this, the producer of the show, the guy who convinced Nasubi to keep going in Korea, his name was Toshio Tsuchiya. Back in the '90s, he was considered the king of Japanese reality TV. Last year, 14 years after Sweepstakes Life ended, Tsuchiya called Nasubi, who wasn't thrilled to hear from him at first.
而这一切的幕后主使，该节目的制片人，那个在韩国说服茄子继续下去的人，名叫土屋敏男。在90年代，他被认为是日本真人秀之王。去年，也就是《抽奖生活》结束14年后，土屋给茄子打了电话，茄子起初并不高兴接到他的电话。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I had some, let's say, mixed feelings about him, a little resentment, maybe. Yeah, I kept my distance for a very long time. And then, actually just last year, he got in touch with me. And apparently it sort of came to his attention that maybe he had put people through maybe more than they deserved. And so he invited me to dinner. And he spent the evening explaining why he did what he did and apologizing.
对他，我有一些混合的情绪，也许有一点怨恨。是的，我保持距离很长时间。然后，实际上就在去年，他联系了我。显然他意识到，也许他让人们经历的苦难远超他们应得的。所以他请我吃晚饭。他花了整整一个晚上解释他为什么这么做，并向我道歉。
I think we-- yeah, I think we pretty much came to terms. And I welcome the opportunity to work with him again, certainly.
我想我们——是的，我想我们基本达成和解了。我当然欢迎再次与他合作的机会。
Wow. You would work with him again. That's really-- [LAUGHS] that is shocking. And what was his reason for putting you through what he did?
哇。你竟然会愿意再次和他合作。这真的很——[笑]这真是令人震惊。他让你经历那些事情的理由到底是什么？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
He wanted something that would move people. And you don't get that out of just somebody playing around. He wanted to see something real. He wanted to pull miracles out of people. It was done for the purpose of getting a miracle on film.
他想要一些能打动人的东西。而你不可能从仅仅是在玩闹的人身上得到那个。他想看到真实的东西。他想从人们身上挖掘出奇迹。这样做就是为了在胶片上留下奇迹。
And that seemed to me like-- well, I'll be honest. It sounds like something an evil puppet master would say. So I had to. I talked to Toshio Tsuchiya on the phone. He's a round, middle-aged guy, bleached platinum blonde hair. He confirmed that he reached out to Nasubi, and that when they met, Nasubi told them very honestly how painful his experience on the show was. Tsuchiya says he listened and was moved.
这对我来说听起来像是——好吧，老实说，这听起来像邪恶木偶大师会说的话。所以我不得不联系了土屋敏男。他是一个圆脸、中年、染着白金发色的家伙。他证实他确实联系了茄子，并且当他们见面时，茄子非常诚实地告诉他，他在节目中的经历是多么痛苦。土屋说他听了并被打动了。
But he says he wasn't sorry, about Nasubi, about any of the segments he produced for Denpa Shonen , about any of the contestants, not in the slightest. I used the same interpreter for our interview that I used for Nasubi's. Here's Tsuchiya.
但他说他并不后悔，关于茄子，关于他为《电波少年》制作的任何片段，关于任何选手，一点也不。我在采访中用了和采访茄子时一样的翻译。这是土屋的话。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
I was enthralled by their struggle. I was thrilled by their personal struggle. So I was watching them succeed. I have no regrets about anything I do to that show.
我被他们的挣扎深深吸引了。我为他们的个人奋斗感到激动。所以我看着他们成功。我不后悔对那个节目做的任何事情。
Nasubi said that you apologized to him when you guys talked. Is that correct, or no?
茄子说你们谈话时你向他道歉了。这是真的吗，还是不是？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
Well, I put him through a lot. If you say this you have a sports team and you have a coach who runs his players through very difficult maneuvers, at the end of the day, he may pat them on the back and say, sorry for putting you through such a rough struggle. It wasn't me expressing that I shouldn't have done the project.
嗯，我确实让他经历了太多。如果你说你有一个运动队，教练让队员进行非常艰难的训练，在一天结束时，他可能会拍拍他们的背说，抱歉让你们经历了这么艰难的挣扎。这并不代表我表达我不该做那个项目。
Tsuchiya has a lot of lofty ideas of what the show was trying to accomplish. And when he talks about them, you do get the sense that it was, in fact, intended to be a sort of psychological experiment.
土屋对节目试图达成的目标有很多崇高的想法。当他谈论这些时，你确实会感觉到，这实际上确实是一个心理实验。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语对话]
The whole project was trying to reach at some very elemental, simple humanity. You see, Nasubi would have been brought to a state where he was at such an elemental part of his existence that he danced without realizing he had ever danced. And he danced on a regular basis.
整个项目试图触及一些非常基本的、单纯的人性。你看，茄子会被带到一种状态，处于他存在的最基本部分，以至于他跳舞时根本没意识到自己在跳舞。他经常跳。
The modern individual is shackled by convention and expectation and all these other things that we wear from day to day. And I wanted to see them drop some of that, to see the simple humanity in them, to see actual gratefulness.
现代个人被传统、期望以及我们每天所穿戴的所有其他东西所束缚。我想看到他们放下一些包袱，看到他们身上淳朴的人性，看到真实的感激之情。
It's weird to think about. But the fact of the matter is, what Tsuchiya's saying is true. Denpa Shonen did really capture humanity in a rare way. A way you don't ever really see, even on the craziest of American reality TV shows. Hungry, starving, alone, unaware that he was being watched, Nasubi was totally innocent and totally animal. Of course, it's cruel to bring a human being to that point. And it takes a special kind of cruelty to take someone at their most vulnerable and add wacky sound effects to their suffering.
想到这些很奇怪。但事实是，土屋所说的是真的。《电波少年》确实以一种罕见的方式捕捉到了人性。即使在美国最疯狂的真人秀中，你也不会看到这种方式。饥饿、瘦骨嶙峋、孤独、不知道自己在被监视，茄子是完全天真且完全动物性的。当然，把一个人逼到那种地步是很残忍的。而且把一个最脆弱的人放在那里，还要在他们的痛苦上加上搞怪的音效，需要一种特殊的残忍。
A couple weeks into Nasubi's challenge, before he won any solid food, when he was hungriest, a delivery man came to the door bearing ramen and stir-fried vegetables. "It's 1,700 yen all together," the man said. "I don't have any money," Nasubi replied. "Sorry, my mistake," the delivery man said, and left. Nasubi sat there, his head hung, a contestant in a real-life hunger game, the smell of ramen lingering in the air.
茄子挑战进行了几周后，在他赢得任何固体食物之前，在他最饥饿的时候，一个送货员来到门口，带着拉面和炒菜。“总共1700日元，”那人说。“我没钱，”茄子回答。“抱歉，我弄错了，”送货员说，然后离开了。茄子坐在那里，垂头丧气，就像现实生活“饥饿游戏”里的选手，拉面的香味在空气中久久不散。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program. Coming up, we go to a land where highway cloverleaves are sunk in a vast meadow, where one man tries to document how things really are. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
斯蒂芬妮·富是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来，我们将前往一片草地，那里有沉入其中的公路立交桥，一个人试图记录现实到底是什么样。节目继续，一分钟后回到芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "Human Spectacle." We have stories of people who go on display in front of others, lots and lots of others, even though they are not so crazy about doing that. We have arrived at Act Two of our program, Act Two, "I Always Feel Like Somebody's Watching Me."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来不同种类的故事。今天的主题是“人类奇观”。我们邀请到了一些故事，关于那些在其他人面前——许多许多人面前——不得不展示自己，即使他们对此并不太热衷的人。我们来到了节目的第二幕，“我总觉得有人在监视我。”
We've talked a lot in today's program so far about reality TV. And of course, what makes reality TV entertaining is very, very simple, and that is editing. Editing-- if they just set up cameras and showed you all 24 hours in anybody's day, you know, how interesting could that possibly be? Well, here is a story of somebody trying just that, a story of everyday people being treated as human spectacle and being treated that way precisely because of their everyday-ness. Ariel Sabar explains.
我们在今天的节目中已经讨论了很多关于真人秀的话题。当然，让真人秀变得有趣的原因非常、非常简单，那就是剪辑。剪辑——如果他们只是架起摄像机，把任何人一天的24小时都展现给你，你知道，那会有多有趣呢？嗯，这里有一个人尝试做这件事的故事，一个关于普通人被当作人类奇观对待，而且正因为他们的普通性而被那样对待的故事。阿里尔·萨巴尔来解释一下。
Here's how it worked. On a Tuesday morning in the spring of 1949, a seven-year-old boy named Raymond Birch was fast asleep in his bed. His mother walked into his bedroom and said, Raymond, time to get up for school. When the boy opened his eyes, he saw a scientist with a clipboard and timer standing in the corner of his room. The scientist, a stranger to the boy, just stared, didn't say a word. The boy squirmed out of bed and reached for his clothes. The scientist wrote, "7:01 AM-- Raymond picked up a sock."
过程是这样的。1949年春天的一个周二早晨，一个叫雷蒙德·伯奇的七岁男孩正在床上熟睡。他的母亲走进卧室说，雷蒙德，该起床去上学了。当男孩睁开眼睛时，他看到一个拿着剪贴板和计时器的科学家站在房间角落。那个科学家，一个对男孩来说的陌生人，只是盯着看，一句话也没说。男孩在床上扭来扭去，伸手拿衣服。科学家写道：“早上7:01——雷蒙德捡起一只袜子。”
In the late 1940s and early '50s, scientists followed kids in houses, schoolyards, and streets across the town of Oskaloosa, Kansas, taking pages of notes on the littlest things they did or said. "6:33 PM-- Bradley walked deliberately to where his sister sat playing with a puppy and hit her on the head, twice, just as hard as he could hit. His sister looked very surprised and annoyed." "11:06 AM-- Fred skidded on the floor so that he fell with his body partially under the sway. He yelled, 'whoops,' and then lay still, since he saw the swing coming back over him." "11:37 AM-- Margaret's mother asked, why can't you play with your dolls and let that go? Margaret kept on painting the pillars before her, neither looking at her mother nor answering her."
在20世纪40年代末和50年代初，科学家们跟随堪萨斯州奥斯卡卢萨镇的孩子们进入家中、操场和街道，对他们所做或所说的最细小的事情都做了大量记录。“晚上6:33——布拉德利刻意走向他妹妹坐着玩小狗的地方，打了她的头两次，尽可能用力地打。他妹妹看起来非常惊讶和恼火。”“上午11:06——弗雷德在地板上打滑，身体部分滑到秋千下。他大喊‘喔，糟糕’，然后一动不动地躺着，因为他看到秋千正朝他荡过来。”“上午11:37——玛格丽特的母亲问，你为什么不能玩你的洋娃娃，别管那个呢？玛格丽特继续画着她面前的柱子，既没有看她妈妈也没有回答她。”
All of this was happening under the watch of a University of Kansas psychologist named Roger Barker, who has bend on taking his field in a radically new direction. Because psychology was still struggling in those days to be taken seriously as a science, most of Barker's colleagues imitated other kinds of scientists, doing lots of experiments in labs. But none of this made sense to Barker. Humans didn't live in laboratories. They lived in the real world.
这一切都发生在堪萨斯大学心理学家罗杰·巴克（Roger Barker）的注视下，他决心将自己的领域引向一个全新的方向。因为当时的心理学还在努力争取被视为一门严肃科学，大多数巴克的同事都在模仿其他学科，在实验室做大量实验。但这在巴克看来毫无意义。人类不是生活在实验室里的，他们生活在真实世界中。
And that's where Barker want to study them-- in the wild, the way a botanist looked at flowers in the field or a primatologist tracked apes through a forest. So when the University of Kansas called in 1947 and asked Barker if he wanted to chair its psychology department, Barker said, I'll take the job, but on one condition. You find me a small town. A dean at the school said he knew just the place-- Oskaloosa, population 725.
而那正是巴克想要研究他们的地方——在野外，就像植物学家在田间观察花朵，或者灵长类动物学家在森林中追踪猿类一样。因此，当堪萨斯大学在1947年打电话问巴克是否愿意担任心理学系主任时，巴克说，我接下这份工作，但有一个条件：你们得给我找个小镇。学校的一位院长说他正好知道一个地方——奥斯卡卢萨，人口725。
When Roger Barker first drove up into the hills of northeastern Kansas to see Oskaloosa, he must have been beside himself. The place was a Norman Rockwell painting-- not too rich, not too poor, sturdy families in modest houses. It was the picture of middle America.
当罗杰·巴克第一次开车进入堪萨斯州东北部的山丘去看奥斯卡卢萨时，他一定欣喜若狂。那地方就像一幅诺曼·洛克威尔的画——不太富，不太穷，朴实的家庭住在普通的房子里。这就是美国中部的写照。
Barker wanted to study what he called "the naturally occurring behavior of free-ranging persons." And to do that, he told his field workers to become part of the scenery-- visible and friendly, but not obtrusive. The last thing we want to do, he said, is give people the guinea pig feeling.
巴克想要研究他所说的“自由活动者在自然发生的行为”。为了做到这一点，他告诉他的外地研究员们要融入风景——可见且友好，但不要引人注目。“我们最不想做的，”他说，“就是给人们那种被当作小白鼠的感觉。”
Barker took his own advice and moved his entire family to Oskaloosa. They settled in a beat-up house near the town square, joined the Presbyterian church, and became active in the town's social and civic organizations. And that left Barker just as exposed as the Oskaloosans he planned to put under his microscope. "You'll be watching us," a local mother told the researchers one day. "But don't forget, we'll be watching you."
巴克自己也遵循了这个建议，把全家搬到了奥斯卡卢萨。他们在镇广场附近的一所旧房子里定居下来，参加长老会教会，并积极参与镇上的社交和市政组织。这让巴克和他计划放在显微镜下研究的奥斯卡卢萨人一样，完全暴露在他人面前。“你们在看着我们，”一位当地母亲有一天告诉研究人员，“但别忘了，我们也在看着你们。”
One of the first things Barker wanted to do in Oskaloosa was to document a day in the life of an ordinary boy. Barker didn't have a hypothesis about the boy or about seven-year-olds. He wasn't testing for anything in particular. He wanted only to show the world that following a kid for a day could produce a ton of interesting data. Scientists could later break down that data in an infinite number of ways, depending on their interests and the goals of their research, which was how little Raymond Birch woke up that morning to find a scientist standing over him.
巴克在奥斯卡卢萨想做的第一件事就是记录一个普通男孩的一天。巴克对这个男孩或七岁孩子并没有假设。他并不是在测试任何特定的东西。他只是想向世界证明，追踪一个孩子一天可以产生大量有趣的数据。科学家们以后可以根据他们的兴趣和研究目标，以无数种方式解析这些数据，这就是为什么小雷蒙德·伯奇那天早上醒来发现有个科学家站在他上方。
On that Tuesday, April 26, 1949, eight researchers, taking turns like runners in a relay race, followed Raymond for 13 hours straight. The book that came out of it, One Boy's Day , was 435 pages long. It had an entry for nearly every minute of Raymond's day. The researchers tried record not just Raymond's words and movements, but also his perceptions, motives, and feelings.
在那天，1949年4月26日周二，八名研究人员像接力赛选手一样轮流，连续13个小时跟踪雷蒙德。由此产生的书《一个男孩的一天》长达435页。雷蒙德一天的每一分钟几乎都有记录。研究人员试图记录的不仅是雷蒙德的话语和动作，还有他的感知、动机和情感。
They noted that Raymond mumbled with a mouthful of toast at breakfast. They followed him as he walked with his mom through her job at the county clerk's office, and looked on as he drew a picture of a cowboy with a long beard. They watched Raymond find a baseball bat in the grass and pick it up.
他们记录了雷蒙德在吃早餐时嘴里塞满吐司含糊不清。他们跟着他和妈妈去县职员办公室上班，看着他画了一个留着长胡子的牛仔。他们观察雷蒙德在草地上发现了一根棒球棒并捡了起来。
"Oh, boy," he said, according to their notes. "He tossed a stone in the air and swung, but accidentally clipped a flag pole-- 8:24 AM. This made a wonderful hollow ringing noise, so he proceeded to hit the flag pole again. 8:25 AM-- He went around and round and around the pole, hitting it with a bat as he did so, until he became so dizzy that he fell down, bat and all."
“噢，天哪，”根据他们的笔记，他说。“他把一块石头抛向空中挥棒，但不小心擦到了旗杆——上午8:24。这发出了奇妙的中空响声，于是他继续打旗杆。上午8:25——他围着旗杆转了一圈又一圈，用棒子打着它，直到头晕目眩摔倒，连棒子一起倒下。”
Even before the book about Raymond's day was published, Barker felt it was destined for greatness. It would find its way onto campuses as a staple of psychology courses, he thought, and into the hands of artists, novelists, and laymen interested in the cultural scene. "We believe it will become a sort of classic and be in demand for a long time," he wrote in a January 1951 letter.
甚至在关于雷蒙德一天的书出版之前，巴克就觉得它注定会成功。他认为，它会进入校园成为心理学课程的必修书，并进入艺术家、小说家和对文化场景感兴趣的外行手中。“我们相信它将成为一种经典，并在很长一段时间内受到欢迎，”他在1951年1月的信中写道。
But One Boy's Day never took off. And by April 1959, Barker, crestfallen, asked Harper & Row to ship him the 70 remainders languishing in its warehouse. Part of the trouble was simply the book's premise. In its defiant first sentence, Barker calls the book, "a scientific document."
但《一个男孩的一天》从未流行起来。到了1959年4月，心灰意冷的巴克请求哈珀柯林斯出版社把滞留在仓库里的70本存货全部运给他。困难的一部分仅仅在于这本书的前提。在充满挑衅的第一句中，巴克称这本书为“一份科学文件”。
But other scientists had a hard time seeing that. The book was just a tick-tock chronology of Raymond's day. There wasn't any theory or analysis. And this annoyed many of the reviewers in serious academic journals. One reviewer wrote, "The reader is struck by the fact that he is encountering only raw data. How can one evaluate such materials without a theoretical framework?" In other words, what does it mean?
但其他科学家很难认同这一点。这本书只是雷蒙德一天的时钟记录。没有任何理论或分析。这惹恼了许多严肃学术期刊的评论家。一位评论家写道：“读者会被这样一个事实所震惊：他遇到的只是原始数据。没有理论框架，怎么能评估这些材料呢？”换句话说，这意味着什么？
Barker lived in Oskaloosa the rest of his life. But he abandoned his day in the life studies after just a few years. There were more revealing and less labor-intensive ways, he discovered, to study human beings in their natural habitats.
巴克在奥斯卡卢萨度过了余生。但他只尝试了几年就放弃了“一天生活”的研究。他发现，研究人类在自然栖息地行为的方法还有更具启发性且不那么费力的方式。
Today, field studies of naturally occurring behavior are no more common in psychology than they were in Barker's time. The costs and logistics are just too staggering. One rare but recent Barker-like effort was conducted by UCLA's Center on the Everyday Life of Families. Researchers there embedded in the homes of 32 middle class families in Los Angeles for a week and videotaped nearly every waking minute.
今天，在心理学中，对自然发生行为的实地研究并不比巴克时代更普遍。成本和后勤工作太惊人了。加州大学洛杉矶分校“家庭日常生活中心”最近进行了一项罕见的、类似于巴克的实验。研究人员在洛杉矶32个中产阶级家庭的家中入驻了一周，录制了几乎每一分钟清醒时间。
But the ratio of cost and effort to interesting results remains as lopsided today as it was in Barker's time. The New York Times reported that, quote, "After more than $9 million and untold thousands of hours of video watching, the researchers found that, well, life in these trenches is exactly what it looks like-- a fire shower of stress, multitasking, and mutual nitpicking."
但成本和努力与有趣结果之间的比率，如今依然和巴克时代一样失衡。《纽约时报》报道称：“在花费超过900万美元和无法计数的数千小时录像观看后，研究人员发现，嗯，这些家庭内部的生活和看起来一模一样——一场压力、多任务处理和互相挑刺的阵雨。”
One guy in particular who is not a big fan of these studies? Raymond Birch, the boy. I tracked him down a few years ago. His real name is Gary Morgan, and he's now a retired utility worker in his early 70s living in Pennsylvania. Roger Barker autographed Gary's copy of One Boy's Day and personally inscribed it, calling Gary its, quote, "real author." But Gary has yet to get past its first pages.
有一个特别的人不喜欢这些研究？那就是那个男孩，雷蒙德·伯奇。我几年前找到了他。他的真名是加里·摩根，现在是一位70出头的退休公用事业工人，住在宾夕法尼亚州。罗杰·巴克在加里的《一个男孩的一天》副本上签名，并亲手写下寄语，称加里是它的“真正作者”。但加里至今还没读完前面的页数。
"I have to say, why is this interesting?" He told me. "There's nothing happening in this book as far as I can tell. What is it going to tell them that I was standing there, chewing on my fingernails?"
“我不得不说，这有什么有趣的？”他告诉我。“据我所知，这本书里什么都没发生。我站在那儿咬指甲，这能告诉他们什么呢？”
Ariel Sabar is the author of The Outsider , a biography of Roger Parker. It's available as an Amazon Kindle Single.
阿里尔·萨巴尔是罗杰·巴克传记《局外人》的作者。它可以在亚马逊Kindle Single上买到。
[MUSIC - "CENTER OF ATTENTION" BY GUSTER]
[音乐 - Guster乐队的《关注焦点》]
Act Three, "The Big Break." So in this story, a comedy act takes to the stage for the biggest show of their lives. And it is a spectacle, though not the one they had in mind. David Segal tells the story.
第三幕，“大突破”。在这个故事里，一个喜剧团体登台表演了他们生命中最盛大的演出。这是一场奇观，尽管不是他们心目中的那场。大卫·塞加尔讲述了这个故事。
Mitzi McCall and Charlie Brill were a sketch comedy act back in the early 1960s, playing small clubs around the country-- mostly in Los Angeles, where they lived. They were married. They still are, actually. And they were struggling. Then one day, they got a phone call that changed their lives.
米齐·麦考尔和查理·布里尔是60年代初的素描喜剧团体，在全国各地的小俱乐部演出——主要是他们居住的洛杉矶。他们是夫妻。其实他们现在还是。他们当时一直在挣扎。直到有一天，他们接到一个改变人生的电话。
We were sitting at home. And I don't know what we were--
我们当时正坐在家里。我不知道我们在干嘛——
Starving.
饿着。
Starving. No, no, we weren't starving. We--
饿着。不，不，我们没饿。我们——
Yes, I was starving.
是的，我饿死了。
Well, you were hungry that day.
好吧，你那天是饿了。
Oh. [LAUGHS] Oh, was that it?
哦。[笑]哦，是那样吗？
Yeah. And the phone rang. And it was our manager, Mace Neufeld. And he said, "Guess what?" "What?" "I got you on The Ed Sullivan Show ." And we let out a scream, because that was the show.
是的。电话响了。是我们的经纪人梅斯·纽菲尔德。他说：“猜猜怎么着？”“什么？”“我让你们上了《埃德·沙利文秀》。”我们尖叫出声，因为那可是那个节目啊。
The ultimate.
终极梦想。
Bigger. If you got a shot on Ed Sullivan, you had a shot at stardom.
更大了。如果你有幸上了埃德·沙利文的节目，你就有了成名的机会。
Yes.
是的。
We were just so thrilled. And immediately we started to work on the piece of material that we selected for The Ed Sullivan Show . And we rehearsed and rehearsed. And we fine-tuned it. We ran down to The Horn in Santa Monica. We broke it in. It got a lovely, lovely reaction. And we told everybody. In fact, I think I sky wrote it over Hollywood. We're on The Ed Sullivan Show , yahoo.
我们简直太激动了。我们立即开始制作我们为《埃德·沙利文秀》选定的材料。我们反复排练。我们微调它。我们冲向圣莫尼卡的“号角”俱乐部。我们进行了试演。反响非常好，非常好。我们告诉了所有人。实际上，我想我还在好莱坞的天空上写了字。我们要上《埃德·沙利文秀》了，耶。
Yeah.
是的。
And we were on our way. Woo!
我们已经在路上了。呜！
This wasn't just a shot at greatness. This was a chance to meet a few of their idols who'd be on the show that night, too-- people like Tessie O'Shea, Georgia Brown, who were both big musical theater stars. But to Charlie and Mitzi, the biggest deal of all was a guy they'd already met.
这不仅是一次迈向伟大的机会。这还是一个能见到当晚也会上台的偶像的机会——像苔丝·奥谢、乔治娅·布朗这样的人，她们都是大型音乐剧明星。但对查理和米齐来说，最重大的事情是一个他们已经见过的人。
We were just-- we were in awe of Frank Gorshin, a great, great, great impressionist.
我们只是——我们对弗兰克·戈辛感到敬畏，他是一位伟大、伟大、伟大的模仿家。
Impressionist.
模仿家。
And the Riddler on Batman .
还有《蝙蝠侠》里的谜语人。
We had probably done maybe something with Frank Gorshin.
我们可能已经和弗兰克·戈辛一起做过一些事情了。
I think it was something for Frank Gorshin. I shined his shoes.
我想是给弗兰克·戈辛做点什么。我帮他擦了鞋。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
And I was so in awe. So we get to New York, and we go to rehearsal by taxi. And there's thousands of people in the streets, clamoring.
我真是太敬畏了。所以我们去了纽约，乘出租车去排练。街上有成千上万的人在喧闹。
And the streets are cordoned off. Is that the word? Cordoned?
街道被警戒线围住了。那是那个词吗？警戒线？
Yeah, cordoned. And I looked at Mitzi. And I said, my god, all this for Frank Gorshin.
是的，警戒线。我看着米齐说，天哪，这一切都是为了弗兰克·戈辛。
They were given the worst dressing room in the building on the top floor, a space they shared with a soda machine. But they didn't care. They were both 26 years old, and they were about to go national. But first, it was time for a dress rehearsal.
他们被安排在了大楼顶层最差的化妆间，和一个自动售货机共用空间。但他们不在乎。他们都26岁了，即将走向全国。但首先，是彩排时间。
Here's the deal. We didn't know that the dress rehearsal was something that was looked at very carefully.
重点是。我们不知道彩排是被非常仔细地观察的对象。
By all the executives.
被所有高管观察。
Exactly.
正是如此。
And they have an audience. We didn't know. We were like coming down in our bathrobes with hair curlers. And we go through our act.
而且他们有观众。我们不知道。我们就像穿着浴袍、带着卷发器走过来。我们过了一遍我们的表演。
And when we get to a punch line, instead of doing--
当我们说到一个梗时，而不是做——
The punch line.
那个梗。
We go, blah, blah, blah.
我们说，blah，blah，blah。
Because we don't want to reveal the punch line. We want the band to laugh.
因为我们不想透露梗。我们希望乐队笑。
Oh, gosh.
哦，天哪。
And we don't want-- you know, it was a secret, our punch line.
而且我们不想——你知道，我们的梗是个秘密。
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
是的。[笑]
So we used to go-- and here we are. And Mitzi, by the way, blah, blah, blah. So then we schlep upstairs to our dressing room. And we hear on the loudspeaker, "McCall and Brill, Mr. Sullivan's office, please. McCall and Brill." So we go down, and we go into Mr. Sullivan's office. And there he was.
所以我们习惯说——这里我们到了。而且米齐，顺便说一下，blah，blah，blah。所以我们背着行李上楼回化妆间。然后我们从扬声器听到：“麦考尔和布里尔，请到沙利文先生的办公室。麦考尔和布里尔。”我们下去，走进沙利文先生的办公室。他就在那儿。
Oh, my gosh.
哦，天哪。
Ed Sullivan.
埃德·沙利文。
[SIGH]
[叹气]
He was sitting in a chair getting made up. And I looked at the man who could make our entire careers. So he said, what you did in dress rehearsal, first of all, I don't get the "blah, blah, blahs." I'm not getting that. And we said, no, Mr. Sullivan, those are our punch lines, and we want them to be fresh.
他坐在椅子上化妆。我看着这个能成就我们整个职业生涯的人。他说，你们在彩排中做的，首先，我不明白那些“blah，blah，blah”。我不明白。我们说，不，沙利文先生，那是我们的梗，我们希望它们保持新鲜感。
And he said, oh, well, I wish you would let us in on them for the dress rehearsal. And he said, the piece of material you're doing is too sophisticated for this audience. And I went, what? Because I had seen The Sullivan Show all my life. And he said, well, there's gonna be mostly 14, 15, 16-year-old girls in the audience tonight and kids.
他说，哦，好吧，我希望你们在彩排时能让我们知道它们。他说，你们做的材料对这个观众群来说太复杂了。我当时想，什么？因为我一生都在看沙利文的节目。他说，今晚观众里大多是14、15、16岁的女孩和孩子们。
And it never occurred to me to say, why? What are we were doing? Like a circus show? And he said, so show me your entire act. And because we were so new and eager to please, we stood there in the office and showed Mr. Sullivan our entire nightclub act, anything we had ever worked on.
我当时根本没想到说，为什么？我们在做什么？就像马戏团表演吗？他说，所以把你们的整个表演给我看。因为我们太新了，太渴望得到认可，我们就站在办公室里给沙利文先生表演了我们所有的夜总会节目，任何我们曾经准备过的东西。
Which was like 25, 30 minutes of--
也就是大约25、30分钟的——
Sketches.
小品。
Blah, blah, blah.
blah，blah，blah。
Yeah, sketches.
是的，小品。
And he said, OK, here's the deal. We're gonna put that first girl that comes in--
他说，好，就这样。我们要把第一个进场的女孩——
In the first sketch.
在第一个小品里。
Mhm.
嗯。
We'll put her in the second sketch. But then you do the other girl that you did in the third sketch in the second sketch.
我们把她放到第二个小品里。但然后你在第二个小品里做你在第三个小品里做的那个女孩。
And then that's what you end with, OK?
然后那是你们结尾的部分，好吗？
And that's what you end with. Now, we went, uh, oh-- OK.
然后那是你们结尾的部分。现在，我们心想，呃，噢——好。
They went back upstairs in something close to a panic. Basically, they had just been told to write a new act, right then and there, instead of the routine they had been fine-tuning for weeks. They might have freaked out, but they didn't have time. The curtain's going up in an hour.
他们回到楼上时几乎处于恐慌状态。基本上，他们刚刚被告知要当场写一个新的表演，而不是他们已经微调了数周的常规表演。他们本可以崩溃，但他们没时间。幕布在一小时后就要拉开了。
We were in a daze. We didn't really know what he said. Should we put the first--
我们当时神志不清。我们真的不知道他在说什么。我们应该把第一个女孩——
What did he say?
他说什么来着？
If we take the first girl and put it in the third. And then there was a knock on the door. The door was open, but there was a knock. And there's this guy standing there with funny hair and granny glasses. And he said--
如果我们把第一个女孩放到第三个小品里。然后有人敲门。门是开着的，但有人敲门。有个家伙站在那儿，留着奇怪的发型，带着老式眼镜。他说——
Give us a Coke, love.
给我一瓶可乐，亲爱的。
Give us a Coke, love. And I looked at Mitzi, and I said, this guy wants a glove or something. I'm not sure what he wanted.
给我一瓶可乐，亲爱的。我看着米齐，我说，这家伙想要手套还是什么。我不确定他想要什么。
"Coke love."
“可乐，亲爱的。”
And he started to laugh. And he said, no, give us a Coke, love.
然后他开始笑。他说，不，给我一瓶可乐，亲爱的。
And he pointed to the machine.
他指了指机器。
The Coke machine. And I said, oh, yeah, well, come in. It's all yours. And he said, can you give me a dime? $0.10. And I said, oh, I got to buy you the coke as well. OK.
可乐机。我说，哦，是的，嗯，进来吧。这全是你的。他说，你能给我一角钱吗？10美分。我说，噢，我还得给你买可乐。好吧。
What do you think, we're made out of money, kid?
你以为我们是金子做的吗，孩子？
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
The worst part was that this guy seemed to want to just hang out. So he helped himself to a seat on the sofa.
最糟糕的是这家伙似乎只想待着。所以他在沙发上给自己找了个座位。
While he's talking to us, he takes out of his pocket a napkin and a pen, and he's drawing me. He's looking at me and he's drawing me.
他跟我们说话时，从口袋里拿出一张餐巾纸和一支笔，他在画我。他看着我，他在画我。
Mhm. Mhm.
嗯。嗯。
That's nice. And he did some pictures of me and Mitzi on napkins.
那很好。他还在餐巾纸上画了一些我和米齐的画。
All we thought about was, I wish this kid would go so we can work on our act.
我们当时脑子里想的都是，我真希望这小子能走，这样我们就能准备表演了。
Yeah.
是的。
Get out of here.
滚出去吧。
We haven't put the first character in the third sketch and the second in the--
我们还没把第一个角色放进第三个小品里，第二个放进——
Ugh, gosh.
唔，天哪。
And he left. And we looked at each other and said, OK, now, what are we doing?
然后他走了。我们看着对方说，好吧，现在，我们该做什么？
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
"All right. McCall and Brill. McCall and Brill on stage for the show."
“好了。麦考尔和布里尔。麦考尔和布里尔上台表演。”
Good evening, ladies and gentlemen. Tonight, live from New York--
晚上好，女士们先生们。今晚，来自纽约的直播——
The show was about to begin. All the performers gathered in the wings, waiting for their turn. Finally, Ed Sullivan came out and announced the first act.
节目就要开始了。所有演员聚集在侧台，等待轮到他们。最后，埃德·沙利文出来并宣布了第一个节目。
Ladies and gentlemen, The Beatles!
女士们先生们，披头士！
[AUDIENCE SCREAMING]
[观众尖叫]
We were on The Ed Sullivan Show with The Beatles.
我们和披头士一起上了《埃德·沙利文秀》。
[MUSIC - "ALL MY LOVING" BY THE BEATLES]
[音乐 - 披头士的《All My Loving》]
We didn't realize that's what the crowds were for, because, to be very honest, we didn't really know who The Beatles were.
我们没意识到人群是为了这个，因为，老实说，我们真的不知道披头士是谁。
Actually, our manager, when he called us and said, you're gonna be on The Ed Sullivan Show , and he said, and guess what? You're gonna be with The Beatles? And we said, who?
实际上，我们的经纪人打电话给我们说，你要上《埃德·沙利文秀》了，他说，猜猜怎么着？你们要和披头士一起？我们说，谁？
[MUSIC - "ALL MY LOVING" BY THE BEATLES]
[音乐 - 披头士的《All My Loving》]
The guy with the pen, the one who drew the pictures? That, of course, was John Lennon. And this was February 9, 1964, the first time a US audience had laid eyes on The Beatles. Years later, Lennon said he thought the kids that night had lost their minds. Charlie, watching from 20 feet away, thought so too.
那个拿笔的家伙，那个画画的人？那当然是约翰·列侬。那是1964年2月9日，美国观众第一次见到披头士。多年后，列侬说他觉得那天晚上的孩子们都疯了。查理在20英尺外看着，也这么想。
Honest to God, my hand to God, I tell you, we couldn't hear them. The screams all through what they did were so loud, I never got a chance to hear what they sound like. Who's singing?
对上帝发誓，我告诉你，我们根本听不见他们。他们表演期间的尖叫声太大了，我从来没机会听听他们听起来是什么样。谁在唱歌？
This was something different.
这是完全不同的东西。
Yeah, I mean, I heard about Sinatra at the Paramount.
是的，我的意思是，我听说过派拉蒙剧院的辛纳屈。
Yeah.
是的。
People were screaming. But this, I never heard of saw such bedlam in my life. Now, when they're finished, the screams keep going on.
人们在尖叫。但这，我一生中从没见过这种混乱。现在，当他们表演结束后，尖叫声还在继续。
[AUDIENCE SCREAMING]
[观众尖叫]
It must have dawned on you at that moment, or was it before, that this was a cultural phenomenon, just off the charts.
那一刻你肯定意识到，或者之前就意识到，这是一个史无前例的文化现象。
I really need to be rigorously honest right now. No, it didn't. No.
我必须非常诚实。没有。没有。
Well, think about. Think it over.
嗯，想一想。再想想。
All right, I'll think it over. No.
好吧，我会想想。没有。
OK.
好。
It never occurred.
从来没这么想过。
No. We were too nervous of what we were gonna do.
没有。我们太紧张我们要做的表演了。
Please.
求你了。
I mean, I knew they were a hit.
我的意思是，我知道他们很火。
But you know what, we hadn't gone on yet. I wanted to know that we were gonna be fabulous.
但你知道吗，我们还没上台呢。我想确保我们能表现得精彩绝伦。
Our careers were at stake here.
我们的事业危在旦夕。
Crazy.
疯了。
73 million Americans watched The Ed Sullivan Show that night, about 40% of the entire country. Ordinarily, when that many people come together, it's for the last episode of a long-running TV series, or for playoff games of teams they already know, not for a show that turns the stage over to an act that nobody's heard of. Arguably, Mitzi and Charlie had the single greatest break in the history of show business.
当晚有7300万美国人观看了《埃德·沙利文秀》，约占全国总人口的40%。通常，当这么多人聚在一起时，是为了看一部长期电视连续剧的最后一集，或者看他们已经熟悉的队伍的季后赛，而不是为了一个节目，把舞台让给一个没人听说过的团体。可以说，米齐和查理拥有了演艺史上单次最大的突破。
People forget this was an hour-long program, with The Beatles playing a few songs at the beginning and then a few songs toward the end. In between, there were six different acts, from vaudeville, from Broadway, from the circus, from everything rock was about to bulldoze aside. It was basically the future sharing a bill with the doomed. Which is why, after The Beatles finished singing "She Loves You," the next thing on The Ed Sullivan Show that night was a guy in a tux doing a card trick.
人们忘了这是一个一小时的节目，披头士在开始唱了几首歌，然后在结尾又唱了几首歌。在这期间，有六个不同的表演，从杂耍、百老汇、马戏团，到所有摇滚乐即将推翻的一切。这基本上是未来与注定消亡的事物共享一个舞台。这就是为什么，在披头士唱完《She Loves You》之后，当晚《埃德·沙利文秀》上的下一件事是一个穿着燕尾服的家伙在表演纸牌戏法。
We do the trick with one, two, three, four red spot cards. Now, from these four red spot cards I take in my right hand-- my right hand is, of course, always the hand with the thumb from the left side. Now, in this hand--
我们用一、二、三、四张红点牌表演戏法。现在，从我右手拿着的这四张红点牌里——我的右手，当然，总是那个左手拇指的一边。现在，在这只手里——
There's an acrobatic novelty act. There's Tessie O'Shea, a very large woman in a sequined gown, playing a banjo, doing her signature tune, "Two Ton Tessie from Tennessee."
有一个杂技表演。苔丝·奥谢来了，一位穿着亮片礼服的高大女性，弹着班卓琴，表演了她的标志性歌曲“田纳西的两吨苔丝”。
[SINGING] They play tennis on her double chin. They call her Two Ton Tessie, Two Ton Tessie from Nashville, Tennessee. Yes, they call her--
[歌唱] 他们在她的双下巴上打网球。他们叫她两吨苔丝，田纳西州纳什维尔的两吨苔丝。是的，他们叫她——
Frank Gorshin comes on with 10 minutes of impersonations-- Dean Martin, Burt Lancaster, Anthony Quinn. The far-fetched conceit of his act doesn't seem quite so far-fetched 40 years later.
弗兰克·戈辛带来了10分钟的模仿表演——迪恩·马丁、伯特·兰卡斯特、安东尼·奎因。40年后看来，他的表演那种荒谬的前提似乎并不那么牵强。
Well, it's election year. And once again, a lot of the Hollywood stars will be out campaigning for the candidates of both parties. Well, a funny thing occurred to me. What if these stars should suddenly decide to run for these offices themselves. They'd have no trouble getting votes because of their popularity. In just a short time, the stars will be running the country.
嗯，这是选举年。好莱坞明星们又会出来为两党的候选人竞选了。嗯，我想到一件有趣的事情。如果这些明星突然决定自己竞选这些职位呢？他们会因为受欢迎而毫无困难地获得选票。在很短的时间内，明星们将管理这个国家。
He imagines a meeting of the US Senate, where character actor Broderick Crawford is vice president and people like Marlon Brando are senators.
他想象了一场美国参议院的会议，性格演员布罗德里克·克劳福德是副总统，马龙·白兰度这样的人是参议员。
Tonight, we're going to discuss what [INAUDIBLE] somebody changed and made the present two-party system [INAUDIBLE]. 10-4.
今晚，我们将讨论什么[听不清]有人改变并制造了现有的两党制[听不清]。10-4。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Mr. Chairman, for years now, year after year after year, there have been just two major parties-- one at Frank Sinatra's house, and the other one at Dean Martin's.
主席先生，多年来，一年又一年，一直只有两个主要政党——一个在弗兰克·辛纳屈家里，另一个在迪恩·马丁家里。
Just two years after this, Ronald Reagan was elected governor of California.
两年后，罗纳德·里根当选为加利福尼亚州州长。
[MUSIC - "THE ARTFUL DODGER" BY DAVY JONES]
[音乐 - 戴维·琼斯的《The Artful Dodger》]
This is "The Artful Dodger" from the musical Oliver , played here by an 18-year-old Davy Jones. When he heard the screams that evening, he thought-- and this is a quote-- "I'd like a little bit of this action." Two years later, he was cast as a member of The Monkees, the made-for-TV knockoff of The Beatles.
这是音乐剧《雾都孤儿》里的《The Artful Dodger》，由18岁的戴维·琼斯演奏。当晚他听到尖叫声时，他想——引用他的话——“我也想要一点这种行动。”两年后，他被选为披头士的电视克隆版乐队——“顽童合唱团”的成员。
Mitzi and Charlie were slated for what was probably the worst slot on the show. They were the last act before The Beatles returned for the final songs.
米齐和查理被安排在了节目中可能是最差的时段。他们是披头士回来唱最后几首歌之前的最后一个节目。
We were in a daze, but we heard them introduce us. We walked out. Now, the screams came on, because they wanted The Beatles.
我们当时神志不清，但我们听到了他们介绍我们。我们走了出去。现在，尖叫声响起了，因为他们想要披头士。
That's when I said I thought I heard "Get them off."
那时候我说我好像听到了“让他们滚下去”。
Yes.
是的。
Did you hear that?
你听到了吗？
I think I said it.
我想是我说的。
Oh. [LAUGHS]
哦。[笑]
Now we take you to Hollywood at a very tense moment in the career of a young, aspiring actress, the office of McCall and Brill.
现在我们把你带到好莱坞，在一位年轻、有抱负的女演员职业生涯中一个非常紧张的时刻，麦考尔和布里尔的办公室。
Miss Tidy, would you come into my office right away, please?
泰迪小姐，请立刻到我的办公室来，好吗？
Yes, sir. Neat, neat, neat, neat. Everything nice and neat, that's me. Hello, sir.
好的，长官。整洁，整洁，整洁，整洁。一切都整洁，那就是我。你好，长官。
Uh, Ms. Tidy, I am having a terrible time trying to find a young actress to star in my next motion picture.
呃，泰迪小姐，我在为我的下一部电影寻找一位年轻女演员时遇到了大麻烦。
Yes, sir.
好的，长官。
Now, are the young ladies outside ready to be interviewed?
现在，外面的年轻女士们准备好接受面试了吗？
Yes, sir, they're neatly waiting outside, sir. I'll send them in.
是的，长官，她们在外面整齐地等着，长官。我会让她们进来。
Just one at a time, Miss Tidy.
一次一个，泰迪小姐。
The premise here is that Charlie is a director casting a movie, and Mitzi is his secretary and then a bunch of different women auditioning for the role. She plays an aspiring starlet.
这里的前提是查理是一位正在选角电影的导演，米齐是他的秘书，然后是一群不同女人在试镜角色。她扮演一个有抱负的小明星。
Hi, sir. Um, you might not remember me, but I was Miss Palm Springs back in 1956.
嗨，长官。嗯，你可能不记得我了，但我曾是1956年的棕榈泉小姐。
A stage mom.
一个舞台妈妈。
Sir, if you're not interested in her, maybe you can be interested in me.
长官，如果你对她不感兴趣，也许你会对我感兴趣。
Well, I'm really not interested.
嗯，我真的不感兴趣。
You know, I have a little talent.
你知道，我有一点天赋。
No, I-- I just wish--
不，我——我只是希望——
[SINGING] 'Cause everything's coming up roses!
[歌唱] 因为一切都在像玫瑰一样绽放！
And a method actor.
还有一位方法派演员。
Then and only then can the true justification of the motivation of our inside urgency henceforth find the infinitesimal need of our outward action. Dig?
只有那样，我们内心紧急状态的真实理由的正当性才能找到我们外在行为的无限需要。懂吗？
Did you notice the dead silence after she says "dig," in a room that only 30 minutes earlier had been filled with the noise that scared the cops? That's a lot of silence.
你注意到她说完“懂吗”之后的死寂了吗？在一个30分钟前还被吓坏警察的噪音充斥的房间里。那沉默持续了很久。
So you were up there for what? How  long do you think? Two minutes or something like that?
所以你们在那儿待了多久？你认为多久？两分钟左右？
It was two years.
待了两年。
Two years.
两年。
We were there for two years.
我们在那儿待了两年。
Mhm.
嗯。
WE started at 24.
我们开始的时候是24岁。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
We didn't know what we were doing. We didn't know if we'd finished the act or didn't finished the act. But the band leader had the punch line, and he played tada! And now you want to see a couple of Jews standing there so nervous, looking to see if Ed would call us over.
我们不知道自己在做什么。我们不知道是否完成了表演或者没完成。但乐队指挥拿着梗，他弹了塔达！现在你想看看一对站在那儿的犹太人，紧张地看着埃德会不会叫我们过去。
If Mr. Sullivan is gonna call us over.
如果沙利文先生叫我们过去。
Because that's what makes you. Did he call us over? No.
因为那是成就你的方式。他叫我们过去了吗？没有。
But I think I saw-- no. Get off.
但我好像看到了——没有。滚开。
No. We were looking at each other, saying, did he motion to us?
没有。我们看着对方，说，他冲我们打手势了吗？
No.
没有。
Wasn't that a motion?
那不是个手势吗？
No. Get off.
没有。滚开。
No, it wasn't get off.
没有，不是滚开。
Did you have a sense at the time that it had gone well or gone poorly?
当时你有没有感觉表演得好还是坏？
No, no. We knew.
没有，没有。我们知道。
We knew
我们知道。
We knew immediately.
我们立刻就知道了。
Into the toilet.
掉进厕所了。
Yeah. Mhm. But see, they didn't have this expression then, but we sucked.
是的。嗯。但是看，他们那时还没这个表达，但我们演砸了。
It was, in fact, the worst three minutes of their lives. They bombed so bad that when they came off stage, people wouldn't look at them. Mitzi's mom dodged their call.
事实上，这是他们一生中最糟糕的三分钟。他们演砸得太厉害，以至于走出舞台时，人们都不看他们。米齐的妈妈躲开了他们的电话。
The biggest terror was that we didn't want to go home.
最大的恐怖是我们不想回家。
We just didn't want to go home.
我们就是不想回家。
We did not want to go back to Los Angeles.
我们不想回到洛杉矶。
But that night, we felt so bad. And Frank Gorshin was nice enough to take us to Downy's.
但那天晚上，我们感觉太糟了。弗兰克·戈辛人很好，带我们去了Downy's。
Sardi's.
萨迪餐厅。
Sardi's. And we had a drink. And he said, don't worry, this is not the end of your lives. And we said, oh, my god.
萨迪餐厅。我们喝了一杯。他说，别担心，这不是你们生命的终点。我们说，噢，天哪。
It was such a fiasco that in 40 years, neither of them have actually seen their performance-- until now. Watching a tape of it, the first thing Charlie noticed was that they actually did get a couple of laughs.
这简直是一场闹剧，40年来他们谁也没看过自己的表演——直到现在。看着录像，查理注意到的第一件事是他们确实得到了一些笑声。
I think I'm gonna be sick.
我想我要吐了。
You made me quiet ill.
你让我很不舒服。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Uh, Ms. Tidy, send in the next young lady, please.
呃，泰迪小姐，请让下一位年轻女士进来。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, we're getting laughs.
是的，我们得到笑声了。
Hi, sir. I'm next the young lady's mother.
嗨，长官。我是下一位年轻女士的妈妈。
How do you do?
你好吗？
My little girl is waiting outside, you know. She used to be one of The Beatles.
我的小女孩在外面等着，你知道。她过去是披头士成员之一。
Oh, what happened?
哦，怎么了？
Somebody stepped on her.
有人踩到她了。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Ha, that was funny. You ad libbed that.
哈，那真好笑。你即兴发挥了。
You know something? We were a hit?
你知道吗？我们演得成功吗？
No, you know it comes from--
不，你知道它来自——
We were a hit. Look at us. Cute.
我们很成功。看看我们。可爱。
You know what? There's something wrong with you. It was pathetic.
你知道吗？你有什么问题。这太可悲了。
The problem, they both say, is that they had to rearrange their act for 14-year-olds in a hurry the day of the broadcast. They're still convinced that if they'd been invited on the show any other night, things would have been different.
他们两人都说，问题在于他们在广播当天不得不匆忙为14岁的孩子们重新安排表演。他们仍然坚信，如果他们被邀请在任何其他晚上上台，情况就会有所不同。
As it happened, they retreated back home, where their agent didn't call for six long months. From then on, they'd wince every time they heard The Beatles. Imagine that. They had the rest of the '60s ahead of them. They were in for a lot of wincing.
碰巧的是，他们退回了家里，经纪人六个月都没给他们打电话。从那时起，每当他们听到披头士，他们就会畏缩。想象一下。他们余下的60年代还在前方。他们注定要经历很多畏缩。
[MUSIC - "REVOLUTION" BY THE BEATLES]
[音乐 - 披头士的《Revolution》]
[MUSIC  - "SGT PEPPER'S LONELY HEARTS CLUB BAND" BY THE BEATLES]
[音乐 - 披头士的《Sgt. Pepper's Lonely Hearts Club Band》]
[MUSIC - "ROCKY RACCOON" BY THE BEATLES]
[音乐 - 披头士的《Rocky Raccoon》]
But Mitzi and Charlie regrouped and recovered, and they had long and fine careers. Through the '60s and '70s, they played nightclubs in Vegas, and they were on television a lot-- goofy stuff, like The Gong Show , but great programs, too, like The Tonight Show , which they were on four times. Mitzi later wrote for sitcoms, like Alf . Charlie eventually landed a leading role on a detective show called Silk Stalkings , which ran on the USA network for nine years. They have a daughter, whom they adore. No knock on Alf , but it gradually dawned on Mitzi and Charlie that on February 9, 1964, they were part of something seismic.
但米齐和查理重整旗鼓，恢复了过来，并拥有了长期且良好的职业生涯。在60和70年代，他们在拉斯维加斯表演夜总会节目，他们也经常上电视——一些搞怪的节目，像《锣秀》，但也有很棒的节目，像《今夜秀》，他们上过四次。米齐后来为情景喜剧写作，像《Alf》。查理最终在一部名为《Silk Stalkings》的侦探剧中担任主角，该剧在USA网络播出长达九年。他们有一个女儿，他们非常疼爱。不批评《Alf》，但米齐和查理逐渐意识到，在1964年2月9日，他们参与了某种地震般的事件。
We were in the midst of greatness.
我们置身于伟大之中。
Yeah.
是的。
We didn't know it. People would come up to us and say, wasn't that you that was on The Beatles show? And we said, yes, yes, waiting for them to say, boy, did you suck. And they went, oh, my god, you're famous.
我们不知道。人们会走到我们面前说，那不是上披头士节目的你们吗？我们说，是的，是的，等待他们说，天哪，你们演得太烂了。他们说，噢，天哪，你们很有名。
Mitzi and Charlie are retired now. Meanwhile, The Beatles have split up. Hell, Wings have split up. But four decades after they flamed out in front of nearly half the country, Mitzi and Charlie are still together, still standing, and still refining the act.
米齐和查理现在退休了。与此同时，披头士解散了。见鬼，Wings也解散了。但在近半个国家面前搞砸表演四十年后，米齐和查理依然在一起，依然站在那里，依然在打磨他们的表演。
I said to Dixie--
我对迪克西说——
Mitzi.
米齐。
Mitzi is my name.
我叫米齐。
I said-- Mitzi. I said to Mitzi--
我说——米齐。我对米齐说——
[SIGH]
[叹气]
--let's go to Florida.
——我们去佛罗里达吧。
Did you call me Dixie?
你刚才叫我迪克西吗？
I think I made a mis--
我想我犯了一个错——
Who's Dixie?
谁是迪克西？
No, nobody.
不，没什么。
No, I mean you're-- what do you have, a girlfriend?
不，我的意思是你——怎么了，你有女朋友了吗？
No! There's no-- there's no Dixie.
不！没有——没有迪克西。
All right, never mind.
好吧，没关系。
It was a slip.
口误。
It doesn't matter.
那无关紧要。
OK.
好的。
Dixie? I mean, I don't--
迪克西？我的意思是，我不——
Forget the Dixie.
忘了那个迪克西吧。
What am I doing in this relationship?
我在这段关系里做什么？
Anyway, I said to Mitzi, we have to go to Florida.
总之，我对米齐说，我们得去佛罗里达。
David Segal. He's a reporter for The New York Times . We first ran this story back in 2005. And since then, Charlie and Mitzi are still going strong. This year, they celebrated their 55th wedding anniversary.
大卫·塞加尔。他是《纽约时报》的记者。我们最初在2005年播出了这个故事。从那时起，查理和米齐一直过得很好。今年，他们庆祝了结婚55周年纪念日。
Well, today's program was produced by Stephanie Foo and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Channa Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show was Julie Snyder.
好了，今天的节目是由斯蒂芬妮·富和我制作的，还有亚历克斯·布鲁姆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、肖恩·科尔、钱娜·乔菲-沃尔特、莎拉·柯尼格、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。今天节目的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。
Production help from Lily Sullivan. Seth Lind is our director of operations. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our business operations manager. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
制作协助来自莉莉·沙利文。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的业务运营经理。金伯利·亨德森是我们的办公室协调员。米歇尔·哈里斯和朱莉·比尔提供研究协助。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·盖迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, at the beginning of this program, when we started This American Life together, even then, he already wanted to disavow any responsibility for what happens here each week. He told me--
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心分发给公共广播电台。感谢一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，在这个节目开始时，当我们共同开启《美国生活》时，即使在那时，他也已经想要撇清对每周在这里发生的事情的任何责任。他告诉我——
This is what I'm going to do. You're going to run the show. But you will now hypnotize me, and I will forget.
这是我要做的。你负责运营节目。但你现在要对我进行催眠，我会忘记。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。